uh are you filming you're just taking a
picture what are we doing why are you
doing a picture okay I always get
paranoid
all right we're going all right hey
what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday December 11th 2017 what's going
on how are ya um it's the Christmas
season everybody Merry Christmas to
everybody I know you're not supposed to
say that anymore I don't know why
somebody said Happy Hanukkah to me I
wouldn't be like you know go [ __ ]
yourself
I'm Christian I'm not even Christian I
didn't go to church I just like say
Merry Christmas he puts a little song in
my heart but in this gift-giving time of
the year the gift that we have today is
very special guests came in all the way
from New York
the wonderfully talented with a brand
new special called naive innocence that
you can get on itunes google play amazon
youporn
right youporn no no okay please welcome
Harris Stanton everybody to the program
hey what's up yeah they should have lost
ever we do have the sound of flex I have
porn in mind my album do you know I'm
trying to go I'm trying to go to the
month of December no point no boo why no
nothing because I think it [ __ ] you up
it does it does if I didn't have to if I
didn't get up so late and had to be here
when I would have jerked off before I
came here but I realize didn't have
enough time to get into it the way I
wanted to
Jesus [ __ ] become a character or
something I watched that flare
documentary was talking about and the
guy acts on me I mean today do you jerk
off it goes twice I like that's about
what I do
Ric Flair said that yeah you saw the
documentary you took I don't remember
that part
yeah he's mental sports our colleges and
the guy was like so how many times do I
go if he goes twice how much do you
drink he goes I have ten beers and in
five vodkas that part I remembered yeah
well he said that before he said to
jerking off stuff before that you know
okay he goes every day every day I love
you doing oh it's 1982 started 72 but
but that's impossible he says but a week
with me yeah I like when they said maybe
like your first wife how
long you faithful to her and he was like
about a day yes and they go really goes
I couldn't do it I couldn't do it I came
home and I he goes I was bored I just
wanted like to see a guy it was great
you actually just say how [ __ ] bored
he is being married cuz you know you
anytime you have a thought of just any
sort of like resentment of your
situation that you [ __ ] created right
he didn't have to say I do you didn't
have to do all that but you created it
you have that net feeling of like [ __ ] I
want to do this you have like that Gil I
loved his complete lack of guilt yeah or
honesty I should honesty yeah honesty
but I don't why do you tell the girls
why do you say scream out your hotel I
don't know why don't you wear your ring
no one ever comes to the hotel they all
come to the hotel I like that one when
he was in the middle of nowhere and
there was no party when he went back to
the hotel he created would they just
created one like a hundred kamikazes yes
dancing on the bar it's just like whoo
yeah you just blew out my [ __ ] sorry
Jesus let me turn this down here I'm
speaking of WordPress yeah man you got
to go with Mike there you go um speaking
of honesty tell me about your uh your
special and I also like how you're doing
it like you're you basically went where
all the specials end up anyways and so
you just bypassed all the networks it's
just like someone's gonna steal this and
rip it in anyways or whatever the kids
say what you just shot it yourself no
it's a bill for the fifth time is the
album what is it oh it's an album oh
it's a CD yeah well it's not a CD it's
just digital I guess and I have drop
cars that I sell after my shows and
stuff alright yeah sorry man yeah I
don't do a lot of interviews and I'm not
a good listener it's okay here we go for
the last time I'm here about a benefit
when's your special come out I just
assume it's a comedian it's got to be a
special now filming at Gotham comedy
club
Memorial Day weekend well how do you
film an album well right I recorded it
at Gotham comedy club more Day weekend
and it's on all the little media
platforms all right 45 minute album I
have to ask you a white guy question
here you're wearing a Philly set alright
now I've learned this with black people
that doesn't mean you're a fan do you
have on maroon sneakers or do you really
like the Phillies I just like the Hat
oh you just like to have yeah I'm a
Toronto Blue Jays man you might see me
wearing a few different Toronto Blue
Jays ads and you have a baseball
background correct yes Chicago Cubs
that's right you were a right fielder I
believe mm-hmm in the 56 round was just
they don't have that round anymore you
draft in the 56 round and in the
scouting report on you as you could go
deep but you couldn't hit a curve ball
yes so what did you do to try to work on
other than just guessing what did you do
when you stepped up to plate to try to
get because there's no [ __ ] way I
could ever hit a curve where I was I was
I was always hunting the fastball which
is probably not a great well that's what
a lot of hitters do equals adjust but I
just I think it was meant to I thought
wow I wish I wish I knew about sports
psychology when I was playing I would
have went to one because it was totally
mental you had a mental block Charles
Barkley's golf swing yeah just stop and
then like Jon Lester who can't throw the
first base but he could throw a pinpoint
fastball on the inside corner to a
hitter but he can't do it the first base
that though somebody out yeah he will
not know it just can throw you ever say
I'll just say [ __ ] throw like like I
don't know what like a goddamn gorilla
on the ground and the second they got to
throw it they throw like a good little
girl like it all right are you all know
if you remember Chuck Knobloch he played
for the yeah he was a Gold Glove second
baseman all of a sudden couldn't catch
anything and we couldn't throw he
couldn't throw West yeah he threw it
yeah he threw was like hitting people
and I guess from yeah Steve sax was the
first guy was that the guy in the other
the yips yeah it's when it's all mental
cuz you were doing it your whole life
until now so did you ever hit the
curveball I've hit a few curveballs bad
ones the ones that don't break that much
okay got a good one that's how many
people hit a good one anyway you're not
gonna hear if Clayton Kershaw puts a
good one on out you're not touching it
what so who's uh anybody you ever go up
against made it in the big leagues yeah
Lando Hudson he's don't go against him
well he didn't know
he didn't pitch he was a player okay
yeah he was playing Jacobs schumake he
got drafted first round by the Toronto
not by Atlanta Braves and um he didn't
make it he got a five hundred thousand
dollar signing bonus
and so you did all that bull durham [ __ ]
riding around in buses and all that no I
didn't make it that far
I was released explained training wait
so when you get drafted by the Cubs they
saw you at high school like where you
saw me in high school and then they uh
they actually can Scouts can actually
help you get into schools they call
other schools and go we like this guy
matter of fact I got uh recruited by NC
State from a scout they they call the
schools and they hey get this guy we're
gonna look at him it didn't you go to
school
I didn't after your first season they
either pick you up or they cuz I was a
drafting father it's just non-stop
pressure yes so every time so then it's
already bad enough if you're in your
head if you're in a slump yes now it's
just like [ __ ] I'm not gonna get picked
up next year my dream is gonna die so
all these other kids are walking around
going to keg parties yeah going mom send
more money and you're in you're
literally going my dreams [ __ ] dying
right right exactly it most people don't
most people don't know baseball it's
just extremely competitive and hard to
play that's why there's a minor leagues
there's no my legs for but there's a
little bit for football now but that's
not my lease for basketball and football
you just go right to the pros but
baseball you need constant work from
rookie ball all the way to triple-a
rookie ball is not even able yet is that
because it's the games that hard it's
really their whole game you ever seen a
97 mile an hour fastball coming at you
and like those people that go down to
the batting cages and they just set it
on 90 and they know what the pitches and
they keep going dude I was hitting it
yeah it's catching up with this okay
yeah all right now let's actually put a
brain behind that [ __ ] machine that
has two other pitches exam there's a
million people watching right fastball
is actually easy to hear it's the other
stuff slider curveball you don't know
what's coming sometime if the pitching
utilize what is what what exactly is a
slider it's a what I'll do
it's a ball dig slice to the left or
slice to the right that's it and yeah
that's not a curveball curveball
drops off the curveball drops off the
table yeah that's a slider they've got a
12 to 6 where really drops from 12 to
singer so back Kershaw has a 12 to 6
somebody
a loop but a slider is a and a cutter is
a fastball that at the last minute darts
to the left which goes into your the
handle part and you break your bat like
Mariano had greatest cutter and it was
just like can't they just guess and just
going I know he's coming with the cutter
and just guess because he was doing a
little left yes he used to play for the
Giants and he owned [ __ ] Tim
Wakefield who was a knuckleball pitcher
and he goes hey this is a visual here
but basically he'd go like well
basically his pitch did this and he
would make all these crazy right oh yes
with this hand and then go it either
went here or there your knuckleball is
crazy he would just guess he would go
I'm gonna just swing here on this one or
I'm gonna swing there and I'm ignoring
all of this [ __ ] between me and him
and he actually was successful doing
there
I remember the Yankees one years we're
just looking at tape against Wakefield
and they realized that most of his
knuckle balls were balls so they go well
just don't [ __ ] swing it and then he
started getting behind in the count I
think that's when he had to like every
once in a while throw like his idea of
like a fastball
but I always felt if I was gonna get to
the big leagues like that's the way to
you know if you could somehow develop a
knuckleball cuz then you're not gonna
blow out your arm right you can throw
like 26 pitches like you know crazy like
Johnson you could pitch to 16 1900s yeah
what do you think I know we're not I
love sports it gives a [ __ ] we know
you're funny let's just write right here
sports what if what if what do you how
do you look at those early 1900s
you know specials on that specials the
[ __ ] records that people in baseball
yeah like when somebody you know he
pitched ninety three innings in two days
that'll never be broken right the Home
Depot League is what I feel like well
today's today's us baseball is different
because it's the training it's a
preparation those guys they just they
just they just played like now they
caught early two players two pitchers
like they only go six innings now really
yeah they're like veal yeah like back in
the day they plan to go nine and right
and now ago you go six and some five I
don't
and that means your bullpen has to be
very good you know we don't have a great
bullpen even I've even heard talk of
which was it was just blasphemy I hope
they never do it that just tried to okay
you go three innings you go three
innings no you let Clayton Kershaw goal
as long as he can go and did you bring
in the bullpen you let him go three and
let your other guy go three I guess
where do you coach any baseball when
you're not doing stand-up no no I'm only
put my son in the league probably next
summer that's good you're gonna keep him
out of football Lisi she didn't pick
soccer I know soccer is gradually taking
over yeah yeah yeah you can't do cuz you
know what she's basically saying Joe
Jackson game in baseball just saying
you're saying I want my son to be a
flopper yeah that's basically I want I
think you have to you got to take like a
drama class before you play soccer or
whatever the [ __ ] they call it overseas
football my favorite one Evers you know
people say you know what do you call it
football talking about American for
Brian right the somebody I think it what
comedian said this is like well why do
you call it football why don't you call
it feetball
right using both feet right you want to
be a clever cut does your clever joke
right back at you right I actually would
rather watch women's soccer than men's
soccer with just because they just play
they don't do all that [ __ ] flopping
around and it's embarrassing right I
would literally if that was my son I
would walk out of the stadium
that's all dramatic like Glenn Close in
the natural right I'd have myself
backlit so he saw me up in the stands
and he'd be all excited that he drew a
[ __ ] yellow card and I would turn my
back on him that'd be it
that'd be the modern-day version in that
story where the guy bricked up the room
that the kid was in oh yeah that you
heard that story no no but I watched the
ID Channel song I mean you eat like a
son he bricked up his son his son was
supposed to go to battle and he [ __ ]
chickened out so the guys came there and
they're like yeah you know yes Sonny you
said it was like the king or some [ __ ]
they go your son who you said was brave
[ __ ] you know he chickened out and he
said [ __ ] no son of mine would do
that and they go yeah he's right in that
room he goes I refuse to believe that
and to demonstrate it I will now have
this room sealed off and he started
brick in the room up and he got all the
way up to the last brick and then the
[ __ ]
was on the other side he would fall
though don't dis right and oh this
happened in Tujunga in Orange County or
something Wow and he goes break it up
now was it they put the last brick in
and that was it the dude died no they
found skeletons with powder blunt dude
it wasn't now it's a it's a fable
I was not real yeah Jesus how crazy do
you think white people are crap free do
you think we are then we can brick our
kids up and have you've done worse
we actually have anyways Jesus Christ
let's get out of slavery what else I
want to talk about the tree so Neil
benefits coming up yes yes man yeah
sorry about that
I always like saying Georgia yeah yeah
actually spoke to her before I came here
what's your favorite Patrice O'Neal
story that you had you went on the road
with him you dated a man and man we
coming back from Charlie good nights
Riley dorm oh yeah I'm you guys fire
crackers is illegal in Boston right
fireworks the fireworks yes go up to New
Hampshire yeah so but you say yeah you
in her to get back in New York I go uh
no because I never really use fireworks
I'll go okay well we stopped by he spent
like three little fireworks
Andy yes just just put them all in one
bag and just drag it up and he goes oh I
wanna set some of this off
so I go yeah I'm from down who's in
North Carolina from here so we just
finally these little abandoned fields so
we did but it was a it was hot and grass
was dry we started a forest fire
uh no oh we lit it up we just came back
from eating so Patrice had tea he
shouldn't have had tea and I had a big
glass of water or tea and the fire
started getting bigger but before it got
bigger we tried to put it stomp it out
so it's just two black dudes like yet
tea would I know we did that we did the
feet first you both had new Snickers oh
nice knickers were blackboard who's
trying to stop this fire out again we
went and grabbed the tea that we both
poured IT on the fire that did nothing I
did I said let's get out of here go no
no we got the in the ambulance came fire
truck came
owner of the land came in ten minutes oh
you said let's get out of your own state
you like [ __ ] this place in New York
yeah let's get out is what happened they
put it out when they set it out and
there were really cool Patrice was
honest Eagles let me do all the talking
stupid and and when they got when they
got there he's like uh I'm from Boston
up on firecrackers before so we just
started to be good oh it's okay man
don't worry about it I just I just put
some pesticide on this crops and
everything is dry or whatever and he let
us go
Wow it took our statement let us go
there you go look at that but we almost
started a forest fire that [ __ ] was
going to cook the field is here and uh
the forest was like maybe ten feet from
my fires light it off in a parking lot
there was no bruising North Carolina
parking lot yeah there is I lived there
well not we were like off the highway
off the beaten path [ __ ] do it a rest
area scare a couple of pedophiles out of
the bathroom yeah we didn't do this
let's put it in this [ __ ] a pile a
hey oh dude it was hilarious our feet
were both of our shoes were black sand
trying to stomp fire report our tea on
it where you got where you work in these
days um everywhere in the city um I'm
actually pretty busy in January I'm
going to Denver Colorado with denotes
and um um Dean Edwards man I haven't run
into him in a minute
yeah yeah where you guys playing out
there
improv was it I was like a funny ball do
Denver Comedy Works
no no no it's doing probably no the
improv okay
and then um after that I am in where am
i I'm in Myrtle Beach where I started at
comedy Cabana how close is that to the
forest fire Myrtle Beach well far as far
as far as far as and stuff no the one
that you [ __ ] started two minutes ago
oh trying to do a callback I was on it
[ __ ] help me out here I was in love
Carolina Oh North Carolina Beach South
South Carolina hey you know I don't like
in the one South the chain Waffle House
oh yeah I just used to work in one you
know I don't like the signage the work
the sign this also the font is so not
exciting and then it's like piss yellow
yeah with like the most basic thing and
you get in there and it's just I don't
there's always like either a fights
about to happen or just happened it's
just really like I worked there three
years and when I was in high school
people go there they seem like they're
hiding out like you know I can't go home
because of such and such situation yeah
it's it's a I didn't enjoy working ahead
how long you worked there for three
years off and on no how many fights did
you say I didn't see any fights but some
one afternoon after I worked third shift
some time and the club and the club let
out these drunk people will come in and
one person went in the bathroom and [ __ ]
everywhere all on the walls so the
waitress comes out she goes hey I'm
cooking food she goes Harris I need you
to clean the bathroom I go what's going
on somebody made the accident I went in
there and it was just it wasn't on
purpose I don't know it looked like a
crime scene with [ __ ] and I said no I'm
not cleaning out I don't get paid to
clean [ __ ] up walls they don't make a
mop for that no they don't
yeah cause call a [ __ ] hazmat group
exactly exactly I refused and one of
them did it and one lady came in and she
wanted a cheeseburger and I said the
cheese is 50 cent extra she goes Vicky
said can she just put it on there I
cooked no lady I can't just do you have
to pay for it and she didn't get the
cheese the next day the next night she
came in she had her own cheese in the
plastic and she said put that on my
burger like you was in a nightclub this
cheese in your glove compartment for two
hours you left your house you got your
purse your perfume and your high heels
and your cheese so you get to the Waffle
House to cook and put it on your burger
because you don't want pay pit you said
Wow hilarious cheapness cuz that is
cheapness if you're going out to a club
and you're gonna pay a cover and you're
gonna do some [ __ ] like that
I [ __ ] hate cheap people oh yeah and
also dumb with money
yes I don't have any sympathy for that
my white girl only goes so far
I mean our white guilt all [ __ ] day
long until I watch you get a deal and
buy a bunch of dumb [ __ ] that's like I
forget it right you know all kinds of
shiny [ __ ] remember that remember the
remember the age of the deals yeah and
Montreal Comedy Festival and everyone
would go up there and be like my dad was
crazy and my brother was crazy
I was like that's a show right and you
go on you get a six-figure deal
remember all those [ __ ] idiots that
went out and they buy flat-screen TV
Harlan did the tiling got a bunch of
money toddlin rest in peace literally
did and I refused to believe it until
Dean Edwards [ __ ] confirmed it did
the coming to America thing where he
fixed up a place he was renting mm-hmm
he even redid the [ __ ] floors he
showed his landlord she raised the rent
and he had to leave after a while yeah
yep yep he bought a bunch about two cars
he he bought that gold Lexus he had the
jeez it was it was in infinity infinity
infinity and he he had a waist length
mink with a hoody on it zip up and he
would be on stage talking about white
people right he must've been you're
never gonna keep money you do that right
he must have spent 20 grand on [ __ ]
hilarious I feel bad going we can't go
that far he's not alive to defend
himself but if he was Felicity was Sarah
the spirit of him yeah do you think in
the afterlife both his arms worked oh
you noticed when each I would have that
arm and people were still afraid of him
he had the mean mug yeah face I used to
always tease him about this Roman nose
yeah
he had like a Julius Caesar [ __ ] nose
yeah he was that he kind of looked like
a male Missy Elliott when I think back
you know what she needs to lose weight
right right right that's sighs Missy
whatever happened to her I think she
took her money left I think Napster all
right which which blew up comedy I'm
convinced too that I'm smart on my money
did it when I acted accident I was I
only did all the only bone can I get any
credit here for going this far in and
not making you [ __ ] relive that again
oh that's fine that we could talk about
it was okay yeah Harris was one of the
people unfortunately who was on the bus
with Tracy Morgan when that Walmart
truck not the bus I'm sorry it was one
of those little those Mercedes likes a
banth and limo party bus without the
pole rest in peace uh Uncle Jim Jimmy
Maggie oh man I remember bombing with
him at [ __ ] the bar that one night
and I remember he was a little boy there
too Oh everybody at that [ __ ] room
that was talents from I never figured
that room out never for that room was
like this really cool bar and it had an
upstairs and a downstairs and it was
Tuesdays the after work Brown mm-hm
you know they never called any white
people remember that it was specifically
all-black crowd after we're crowded the
only time I went to horn I think I must
have killed first because I went back
right right right so I killed the first
time then I bombed then I killed I
bombed every other [ __ ] time it was
unbelievably only did it twice bomb both
terms
oh I mean one night as bad when I was
new anyway
oh I'm so bad you never bomb so bad that
the next guy's bombing offer your bomb
like that's like it's like a half-caf
the shock of what the [ __ ] I did so
Uncle Jimmy went up there and was
bombing and he was bombing so bad and
was so [ __ ] quiet he was just that
guy may have [ __ ] y'all goes I and this
woman was giving him [ __ ] and he said
something about like whatever you know
something about his career right I did I
still got my [ __ ] career and she was
like n-word what career and every but I
was the biggest laugh everyone laughed
at him he was trying to talk about being
on be et dude you remember
what's-his-face Gerald Kelly Gerald
Kelly I abandoned I did one of his rooms
out in Jersey he was one of these places
it was a dance club and like the next
week it was closed because someone shot
off their guns or some [ __ ] and I
[ __ ] went in there and it was me and
Roz G and I forget who else and he was
supposed he was supposed to host it was
his Roman he's like [ __ ] two hours
late and he came onstage
oh yeah I just was like he's like yo
what up you know just got back from
Atlanta
and he goes dude comicview he goes made
six G's he made six Grand doing comic
you know people not in the business
comic view you got paid like 600 bucks I
got thousand dollars one time did you I
think that was actually after everybody
mmm was in the hundreds it was like 700
bucks
all-inclusive like you lost money you
lost money yeah yeah your hotel you to
pay for your flight so he [ __ ] nobody
knows that so he showed up told the
crowd that had waited for him like [ __ ]
axl rose back in the day dead he was
late because he was doing a TV show and
he made six grand a Silurian so that's
how we start everything like what the
[ __ ] I remember Roz went up and she had
such a tough set that she ended her set
and she goes damn she goes I don't know
who's coming up next but he better be
funny cuz you [ __ ] ain't
laughing at [ __ ] and walked off right
and then they brought me up and of
course the second I talked everybody did
the white guy voice I hate it
Jimmy I tell you funny story with Jimmy
on cuz Jimmy head out I guess he was
away for comedy for a little while so
Tracy brought him on the roads and it
was on told us but before I got on a
tour mark field both said that Jimmy
will go up and open and be bombing so
Tracy said Jimmy go up warm the crowd up
and just will go up and Jimmy started
bombing and then uh already comes back
and goes you'll Tracy
Jimmy's bomb you want me to get him off
Tracy's like no no let him simmer for a
little bit yo Jimmy stretch it Jimmy
turns around goes okay they want me to
stay out here and he just bombed for
five more minutes like Tracy you're an
[ __ ] well just let him sit in his
bomb for five more minutes let him out
off the hook man and before then so the
next night he goes Jimmy you represent
your sounded like that dude in Pulp
Fiction let it simmer a little bit and
then so the next night Jimmy Tracy goes
Jimmy you're on again tonight and Jimmy
literally went in the corner and started
rehearsing his lines like new comics
anyone beginner bunch of those there was
a guy I remember when I was in Boston
this guy this guy dick Doherty he still
has rooms he had all of these [ __ ]
rooms right he was like The Godfather of
the outside the satellite rooms right he
had the domain clubs in Boston and then
he had all of these places in like [ __ ]
and Drake it and all these places in
Massachusetts and which are all great
towns but you know not the best place
sometimes to do comedy so he finally did
one he finally got one in Boston I guess
he always had the
he had the comedy ball for a while but
he opened this other one in Kenmore
Square right in the college area and
they called the comedy comedy campus so
this this journeyman guy finally you
know that gives him the room like your
book in this room you host it and he's
[ __ ] psyched right man I'm finally
[ __ ] making something in this
business and he [ __ ] the first night
of it I'm on it with Greg Fitzsimmons
and the dude goes up and it's just
really small crowd ten fifteen people
won't do what I tell you he didn't get a
[ __ ] laugh he got nothing brings up
the first act the first act immediately
starts killing crowd [ __ ] live-ins up
everything's going great
dude finishes his set thanks a lot back
to you host so and so host comes back up
immediately bombing again no bomb yet
that's always playing when the host is
bomb and also bombs again brings up the
woman that Greg was dating at the time
[ __ ] she kills back to him bombing so
finally brings up one more person that
person is killing right so [ __ ]
Fitzsimmons looks at him and he just
goes hey buddy he goes dude you know if
if it's not happening for you just bring
acts up you know we got plenty of show
here we got plenty of show and like piss
this guy off so he got on stage and he
[ __ ] immediately just starts bombing
again so finally dead soundless he just
looks at the crowd you know what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] jokes do you [ __ ] people
want exactly this guy in the crowd goes
how about some funny jokes he goes he
goes funny how like things going in and
out of Uranus oh that's that Dannette
kill it killed with me and Greg that's
hilarious he said it was such [ __ ]
vile in his voice you actually pictures
this guy's [ __ ] puckering up that's
your the kitty me and Greg work it was a
funniest joke of the night he was right
Larry's and the crowd was just like oh
you mean with Kevin Hart sweet cheeks in
Atlantic City I never did that one but I
remember they threw chicken at they
loved they bought it no it was on wheat
cheeks it sounds like a gay bar Patrice
worked at gay bar called Fiddlesticks
I didn't want it was called Queen of
Hearts
oh man no it wasn't a gay bar it's
actually the opposite gangsters hung
ideas fights all the time
and they love little Kevin and but when
everybody else will come back on they
would just they do like a little plastic
that you put the menu in on the table
they do that at jamika
they just they were awful but they love
keV I was like well that guy is funny
too
oh I I didn't do rooms like that after a
while like there was a if enough he'll a
snack if enough people came back with
stories yeah cam was trying to get me to
do that room and I remember I was far
enough in my career which I don't have
to do it I don't need to drive to Philly
to bomb like I get I can do that I'll do
drew Frazier's from Manhattan proper
yeah I'll take the e to the end that
just finally closed to take my I love
that room I've had one time doing that
air on the term - I've been doing that
one time and I remember one entourage
chasing another entourage out of a club
and then the next week there was like a
metal detector yeah yeah - parking
gangsters used to hang out based on
cases used to hang out there like real
live drug dealers
yeah that was the vibe but then it's
really cool after work yeah it was there
yeah like supreme he was on American
Gangster
he they used to hang out there there was
not a guy there named supreme you
probably didn't know when your whiteness
you had no idea makes it probably
thought I was a cop some people used to
do when I got off the [ __ ] when I
took the e to Jamaica Queens and get up
they would look at me like they would
just be like people try to help me
Jamaica Queens I'm like Oh get back on
you want to go yeah you want to go the
other way you know you was performing in
front of killers did you know yeah I
knew that there was definitely some [ __ ]
going on that wasn't legal but I mean I
thought it was kind of like do you ever
think about that how many how many like
people that killed somebody at this
point how long you been doing stand-up
how many people in the crowd who have
killed somebody that people just don't
even know yet all right I just think
that on the subway right well in
Manhattan probably you definitely had it
some clientele and it kills them I know
I had somebody killed some some future
stars are for the first 48 yes let me
off are into the semi yeah half hour
okay cool look at me still can fill a
half huh I got type him a goddamn
password I'm
named you special again so people know
to look for name my special CD sorry
naive innocence and that's the theme cuz
I moved from South Carolina and I was
naive innocent and I got a period and I
got wrong you guys and I became [ __ ]
terrible
you're gonna blame us like that demon
wasn't in you yeah it was in there but
you guys I haven't even talked about
half the [ __ ] [ __ ] that I heard you
did lubricated it out you guys
lubricated it out now you are you were
you are on your own you remember you
already did hell over [ __ ] night
overnight you just went from like hey
how's it going everybody to Harris did
what Harris did what yeah it's pretty
well yeah and I'm just leaving this open
you want to tell your [ __ ] stories
you tell them but other than I keep my
mouth shut
there you go yeah goes into falsetto
[Music]
alright let me do let me do a little
read here real quickly uh-oh look who's
back for the holiday season is Cheri's
berries
Christmas is a week away talk about last
minute shopping nightmares or do you
want me to talk about it going to the
mall at midnight okay
[ __ ] you everybody knows this no it's
actually not that bad this year because
everybody's shopping online yeah yeah
like you're just there with like [ __ ]
people as old as me alright how shopping
with sharise berries has been a
lifesaver
oh yeah dude I'm so sick of these people
who are clearly stocking stuffers acting
like you're buying somebody a [ __ ]
Lexus like like this oh I don't want to
go to the stores I'll just get some of
you some chocolate-covered strawberries
in that dough I'm gonna get those for my
wife I'll just get those only and see
how my [ __ ] holidays go see how my
2018 is anyways no matter how no matter
who you're shopping for this holiday
season sharise berries has the perfect
gift for everyone on your list this
holiday my listeners can get fresh and
delicious cherries berries dipped in
white milk and dark chocolate goodness
why did white come first Harris starting
white always comes that's right because
it's pure starting at 1999 women the
women yeah plus shipping and handling or
check this out when you double the
berries double the berries for just $10
more your gift will include a free
keepsake dessert platter however the
white chocolate is still the same price
um kidding I just want to see your
Facebook and that's two gifts in one you
know the white ones come with little
clan ho doughnut dragon there's only one
way to get this amazing something the
south is gonna order I'll have me
[ __ ] perfect mark there's only one
way you know that's a made-up name cuz
it wasn't two names right
mark mark Bobby there's only one you
Billy Joe would love one of them clay
you know ask I keep the hood I keep the
hood I put it on my gerbil there's only
one way to get these amazing 1999 deal
this holiday visit berries calm click on
the microphone in the upper right hand
corner enter my code bird checkout
remember when you double the berries for
just $10 more your gift will include a
free keepsake dinner a desert plant
platter Christmas is a week away ordered
today that's berries calm code bur which
white hate groups supremest ends you the
least Klan neo-nazis or just the average
douche on YouTube
good question probably Klan even though
they're out there and they're just kind
of saying it why I would think the
YouTube because it's all you know you
might even run into that they might even
know that guy but they don't have the
balls to put on a uniform say what
they're thinking okay yeah the Klan is
just like it's funny to me no like you
know I see it on some of these talk
shows I tell you something that's the
only place they are yes the Klan is only
I'm as white as it gets I've never been
asked to join I don't know any [ __ ]
members all right I've been all through
the South hehe I've been in Connecticut
evidently got a good following in
Connecticut you know as prominent as
they used to be I guess they kind of
fell off yeah it's like the mob they're
all doing like identity theft now and a
[ __ ] whip you know alright he looks
everybody HELOCs there are a ton of
online mattress
tailors popping up these days all with
the one-size-fits-all solution for
better sleep to a better sleep guess
what one size fits all doesn't work when
it comes to mattresses helix sleep
offers something that doesn't exist
anywhere anywhere else a mattress
personalized to your unique preference
and sleeping style that won't set you
back thousands of dollars that's true
like even not not just your height like
if you sleep facedown they take a
plaster mold or your junk so it contours
to the mattress it's true are you
serious no go to helix sleep calm / / I
mean take their two to three minutes
sleep quiz they'll build a custom
mattress that will would be the best
thing you've ever slept on for couples
they even personalize each side of the
mattress which we do know that's the
beginning of the end of the relationship
you're starting to live separate lives
you can't even sleep next to the person
you need your own space everyone from GQ
to Cosmopolitan to the New York Times
are talking to vibe magazine reaching
out to your people they still do they
still have that megan's no I just there
was the last black magazine I remember a
beanie evany jet TV Guide are all
talking about helix and once you try it
out you'll know why your custom masterís
arrives direct to your door in a week
and shipping is completely free try it
for a hundred nights if you don't love
it they'll pick it up gross and refund
you in full all right go to helix sleep
calm / / right now get to get $50 off
your custom mattress that's hellix sleep
calm / BER for $50 off your orders helix
sleep calm / / alright we got two more
here oh here we go me undies everybody
but I bought me undies me undies they'll
take a mold of your junk to do do doop
me undies me undies flip over and they
measure your trunk if I'm sorry I'm me
undies everyone every year millions of
people receive at least the least like
gift of all time underwear Harris
what if someone gave you underwear for
Christmas I would love it cuz most want
/ have holes in because I want those
guys who just I won't buy new underwear
into someone well your former baseball
player you're superstitious right you
hit your last curve ball that pair
underwear you're still going
we're right yeah um well listen this me
undies okay that look good I love socks
now I'm trying to do a segue back into
this [ __ ] copy and I can't do it
anyways but we still give it to our
family and our loved ones who just don't
want underwear but maybe it's not that
underwear is the problem maybe it's the
kind of underwear Harris Harris can I
take a moment here to tell you about me
undies
the only underwear that makes for an
amazing gift the only underwear even
though you probably take a three-pack of
some [ __ ] at Marshalls the undies made
underwear the perfect gift that everyone
is gonna love you for it's a goddamn
holiday miracle this huh this year don't
give underwear give me undies this
holiday season to get your exclusive 20%
off the softest underwear and socks you
will ever wear free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guaranteed go to me undies
dot-com slash bird that's my undies calm
slash / they just have all this [ __ ] in
there that they were softer than cotton
sorry man last last but not least all
right
stamps.com Harris do you go to the post
office ever I not recently no how do you
get your mail up I don't know she didn't
do you do you do it online yeah yeah
comfortable with that do you bank online
yeah do you jerk off online and when you
do do you cover the camera no I don't
jerk off online you don't jerk off
online what do you have a job while I'm
online that's what I mean you use online
porn yes yes the porn I watched you
don't cover the camera there's not a
camera there's a camera right here yeah
but now what I'm watching
pornhub business right there that's a
camera see the tape I got over there but
you know what I found out now now when
you click on a point of all of a sudden
like the whole screen ago like they just
took a picture of you go and look it on
the video no this is the thing I use my
phone most the time you use your phone
well where are you home put my phone you
got that go-to eyesight and you can't
hit a [ __ ] curveball it's not a big
ball - that's un-fuckin'-believable well
the phone's not moving right it's like
golf
all right stamps calm everybody
stamps.com brings all this service of
the US Post Office right to your
fingertips
all right buying print official US
postage for any lead
any package any class of mail using your
own computer and printer then the
mailman comes and picks that [ __ ] up
stamps combs makes it easy you don't
have to use your brain they'll send you
a digital scale automatically calculates
the exact postage stamps comb will even
help you decide the best class of mail
every time print postage any day any
time stares calm is always open I use
stamps calm whenever I'm [ __ ] sending
on my posters I'm a [ __ ] Harris you
know that if I can figure it out so can
you and right now you too can enjoy the
stamps.com service with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale without long
term commitments go to stamps com click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type type in birbee URR
that stamps comm enter ber okay alright
how far in are we and you have 40 okay
10 minutes of [ __ ] there sorry you
have a table that's the camera just so
people don't watch you jerk-off does
that really I just feel no I'm just like
what if you're banging your wife and you
just have your thing on like these
[ __ ] nerds you know they're not
getting any [ __ ] they just watch you
they actually caught people like they
they want to buy a TV they watch you
watching TV yeah and for some reason
that's not illegal and now all these
[ __ ] morons who are they they got
that that little thing there in the
house being like Alexis
yeah you just bugged your own house I
mean you already have with all these
devices and now you got this other thing
right that's like X I'm not all have
licks in my house no it's like inviting
a vampire into your house you got to put
a thing of garlic around his [ __ ]
[ __ ] out my house [ __ ] that's exactly
what I said ok here we go I was bad time
you know we both took a sip all right
here's some questions all right now I
tried to get some ethnically diverse
ones so I can show you there then I'm
woke how annoying is that the hair white
person to say that by the way are you
married to a black woman uh-huh
yeah but you know once you're married
that long that's just a woman you know
it's the same you have cultural fight
yeah it's now hold the fork like this
and I hold it like that Wow there really
is a difference it's
the same [ __ ] right right like can I
finish up here in the bathroom before
you try to steal the sink brushing your
teeth it's the exact same [ __ ] right
it's only when you go out in public and
everybody's like what the [ __ ] you do
you [ __ ] race traitor when you're in
the house I love all you can have mine
you could have mine whatever one I was
supposed to be with and I shook yours
there you go
and then one day we'll go on a double
date like those too freaky [ __ ] was
it the Yankees and the Indians near the
but them that they swapped wives no
there was two teammates they went on a
double date by the end of the end of the
date
they [ __ ] realized a man we're like
sorta like you know they probably sat at
a 4-top boy-girl-boy-girl and I think
they just sort of uh the dudes stop
talking to each other and chicks top top
usually by the end of it someday they
agreed to switch swap wives you like to
go play ever like yeah and I think one
of them made it and the other ones
didn't that's hilarious
the other one didn't that'd be the
funniest fight ever I should have stayed
with the rightfielder well I know he's
getting a better blow job than IMO's
would be brutal all right here we go so
I tried to have some ethnically diverse
okay so I want to start this is a nice
one that I feel like anybody of any sort
of background transgendered anybody
this one's called favorite Ozzy Osbourne
guitarist so this is right in your
wheelhouse this is a fastball I feel
like you could jump on this one why is
this in my wheelhouse Breaking Bad bill
I'm watching a documentary on Ozzie
that's four hours long and boozing while
the girlfriend is out with the her peers
doing Sex in the City [ __ ] while Randy
Rhoads always gets to me especially
during mr. Crowley that none of this
means anything to you my favorite has
always been J Keeley I grew up on bark
at the moon when I was a kid and still
listen now and again to the last furious
riffs of Jake in the last minute of the
song I always felt he was
underappreciated could not agree more
Zakk Wylde is all good but it feels like
he's using five petals instead of
showing pure skill or he should have
seen Zakk Wylde when he played with the
Allman Brothers
that would have cured all of that [ __ ]
for you more style than substance I
don't agree with that what do you think
drummer boy PS was great to see you
Montreal last summer when it was your
birthday all right
what do you think Harris just by the
names alone who would you think is is
the best guitars would you go with Randy
Rhoads Jake Ely or Zakk Wylde probably
Zakk Wylde Zakk Wylde buy because it's
wild J Keeley what does that sound like
to you J Keeley sounds like borderline
agent yeah what am I agent trying to fit
into the culture
okay and Randy Rhoads Randy Rhoads as a
racist
died in a plane crash by the way oh yes
go easier this is like me iPhone a to
puck for a lot of weight right right oh
sorry I don't know I don't know I would
never say that if I don't know well he
did play in an all-white bench so I mean
your theory does work [ __ ] racist no
no is it brutal story he was on tour
with Ozzy Ozzy left Black Sabbath
alright and that would be no that that
would be well whatever they had a
falling-out mm-hmm you'd be like what
relate to you here well it'd be like
something the wu-tang clan they leave
and then they put out a solo album ATS
that's critical there right but boo Tang
never really broke up right no not
really just haven't moved out okay well
just say they broke up and then all of a
sudden you know one of those guys that's
not old dirty bastard Method Man
Ghostface killer decides I'm gonna
[ __ ] put one out you know right you
know it's a very it's a very like
precarious point in your career like you
don't get a second solo album if the
first one bombs especially if you know
came out a supergroup so wrote Black
Sabbath thing was over he was coming out
on his [ __ ] own and he ended up
meeting Randy Rhoads and Randy Rhoads
basically saved his [ __ ] career hmm
so they go out on tour he's destroying
he's like the new guy and everything and
they were in Florida
and they pulled in in the bus driver
wherever they were gonna gas up the bus
that was also a little plane there yeah
and this guy had a pilot's license and
he [ __ ] got in the plane with Randy
Rhoads and he was [ __ ] buzzing the bus
doing all of that [ __ ] and in his last
pass clip the bus and either flew into
the house or into the barn one of the
other and then that was it just crazy
that was it and you just said he sounded
like a racist I hope you're happy
no man you know maybe if you shouldn't
be googling all your [ __ ] porn you
could look up Randy Rhoads before you
soiled his name alright here we go
here's here's one that yeah but we can
both jump on here alright girlfriend
isn't very attractive and I want a cheat
all right
I've been dating my girl for a year now
and I love the [ __ ] out of her but
goddamn if she isn't on the wrong side
of the ten-point scale
oh my god what a [ __ ] yeah you don't
love her no and why would you date her
if she's ugly if you think she's ugly Ya
Ya Ya Ya you don't love this woman no
all right we got it it's not like
there's anything wrong with their face
she's just not really my type physically
personally personally wise does he fight
physically personal personally we jive
Lee says personally wise personality
wise sorry we jive like crazy mmm jive
this guy's got to be like 50 yeah it's
like dude what do you look like does he
eat food or he doesn't like to let's say
she's really pretty
when I'm laying on top or next to her
but any other position and I can't help
but he disappointed and how overweight
she is this guy's a [ __ ] monster he
sure is on one hand the sensation of
being with thick girls really appeals to
me on the other my male gaze does not
agree because of this I found my
thoughts wandering two other women have
started flirting with them for seemingly
no reason
I'm afraid I'm gonna cheat but I really
think all things considered that I could
marry this girl this guy's all over the
[ __ ] map yeah he is breaking up with
her for something so shallow would
absolutely kill me and it hurt the woman
I love love's heart for no reason what
should I do
go see a therapist yeah he's like oddly
like brood
be honest he he's being brutally honest
here but he's all hoped like he makes no
sense I like purple but I don't like
purple which is it pick pick the pros
and cons and you know he already does he
made a very mature move where he
actually fell in love with the person
and now I think that that's getting old
yeah you know there's no more surprises
now he's just looking at her and I think
that that's what's going on exactly
what's going on all right now how can he
for Christmas what gift can he give her
then in a funny loving way can be like
you need to lose some weight or I'm
gonna cheat on you
Sherri's berries there is no way there
is no way like you know the end of an
action movie words which wire do I clip
right and they [ __ ] take a guess yeah
both of them blow up yeah all right
Harris I got to put you on the spot how
would you do it how would you tell the
woman you love personality-wise you guys
jive is this guy says how the [ __ ] would
you tell her you're putting on too much
weight well if you know someone that
long then you go bitching fat you didn't
lose some weight so you rip the band-aid
off right good listen you're getting a
little overweight I had a boy a friend
of mine who dumped his grow he warned
her before I would doing it why they
were dating he said if you get big I'm
out of here
she got big he was out of there she
tested him she ate too much and he said
that he said that to it and he left her
crying I told you I what did I say I
don't look in the mirror look what did I
say you're a hundred pounds bigger than
you was when I said that [ __ ] but here's
the thing though I actually think there
is like a complete lack of respect for
your partner if if you let yourself go
absolutely there is now here's the thing
unless you know you're sick or something
oh you know she comes she was pregnant
[ __ ] all that before having kids or if
you're not having kids all right
if you're sitting a man a woman if
you're just sitting there just becoming
a [ __ ] lard ass exactly
what what are they supposed to do
exactly putting a lot of pressure like
Patrice a whenever you how will you look
to get him
you have to somewhat maintain yeah yeah
otherwise he's gonna eventually where
animals were my like weak and what I
loved about Patrice is he could be that
overweight in the crowd they would never
even think to say like well what about
you
right right right yeah I don't know what
what should he do um talk to her like
you talking to you
only I would just say this I would put
it on me this is what I would do this is
this if you really loved her I'd put on
20 pounds myself and then just be like
listen man I got to get this weight off
you get diabetes buster yeah if I loved
her I would put on 20 pounds myself and
just say listen I got to get this weight
off but I can't do it on my own I need
you okay I've been weak lately I need
you to and she'll be there for you and
you take around and walk this is what
you do you bought I wouldn't do that my
dumper no I wouldn't you buy his and her
[ __ ] matching workout [ __ ] outfits
walk just steer right into it just walk
and be that couple that dresses the same
right oh I know that's when it's just
like that's either like whenever I see
that that's like either they literally
are soul mates if you believe in that or
there's one person that needs to be
rescued from that relationship because
the other person like who's that guy in
the NBA what Ric Flair do what would
Rick flair do well he wouldn't be around
long enough fur to get fat when he came
home from the road when she [ __ ] put
on all that weight he'd do the flair
flop right in front of it just turn
around or you do the Henry Hill you just
do that laughs remember that and he got
walked roans right back around and he
gets he gets back and I got that [ __ ]
kind of people a day gets back in the
car with Joe Pesci I think that's what
he would do um this guy I think he was
trying to be sometimes people try to be
funny by being really blunt I actually
think this guy does really like this
girl but like yeah cuz I think if they
start getting that fat before you had
kids you just start thinking like oh my
god yeah
I don't want to be with a what no one
wants to be with though no one wants to
be a whale and no one wants to be with
the whale with some some guys like big
women okay he doesn't know he likes well
thicken in in sunken obese my father had
a best friend who one of his woman as
fat as she could be oh he did yeah he
had a best friend she was his wife was a
fat what is that about
I don't I think he like you know your
likeness um this is what's so weird
do you know maybe they want him to just
look adorable you know horrible a baby
looks with all those roles of like a
roll of fat in the mid for I'm you're
looking like what is that what is that I
think they want that they just want a
big a big giant baby I think is a lot of
they like a lot of woman but I like a
lot of one but far as like not fat but
like they say six five eleven that's a
lot of woman too
yes I understand what you saying but
it's not fat not fat what's what's the
biggest you will go give me height and
weight let's break down your draft picks
and then the foot in the first round of
the big girl draft Kara Stanton picks
picks a hundred and eighty five pound
six foot no five time
how tall are you I'm six two and a half
six two and a half all right yeah so she
has to if you're gonna weigh 200 pounds
you have to be 511 and better otherwise
you just yeah a fat [ __ ] you know
that's considered insensitive but it's
actually there's an endearing thing
where you're just being brutally honest
I mean that's that's what your heart is
saying yes it's saying you're a fat
[ __ ] it's not being like listen um
right yeah hearts doing all the work
yeah I would I would go whatever cuz I'm
like I'm five nine three quarters I'm
exactly Doug Flutie height not quite 510
big woman with curves are have a chance
like if you steal you know the fat women
out there are really fat but you can
still see the curve yeah a curvy like
a skinny woman but fat yeah a giant just
sack of fat right I would say I would
say 165 mostly because I'm about 175 I
don't want to throw me around the
[ __ ] room what height is it like five
five
jeez five six that's big yeah that's not
that big depends you know depends five
five 160 pounds I don't like those
cankles but when the ankles run into the
total foot you know it's weird
yes it is when you got they got fat feet
and skinny toes oh yeah it's like
someone was that you know the carnival
right way to slam the hammer down trying
to win that prize and they hit a mid
feet right you've heard Corey Holcomb
there's a [ __ ] underrated Camille
absolutely he's not underrated in my
[ __ ] head but uh he a felony welcome
you ever [ __ ] a fat girl with regular
people legs but goddamn I just [ __ ] the
Hamburglar that's usually an alcoholic
body they say there was a guy that I
used to work with who I found out
recently died which wasn't a surprise he
was like the biggest booze hound
cokehead he was like six five oh wow
it was funny man he was just big just
like dude his legs were as skinny as
mine and he would push his jeans down
and just up top it was all was just all
booze and burgers and it did blow and he
had but he had like his arms and legs
was like he never worked out in his life
was just skinny as [ __ ] and he just kept
all of that stuff there and I think he
died of a heart attack that's it right
there which is why going back to this
guy it's just like that's another thing
you have to look at gonna be like I'm
gonna be a widower mm-hm in my mid-50s
um there's got to be an exercise video
just to get rid of your fat feet or at
least to fatten up your toes right you
should get like you know that feet you
should get like the ass injections in
your toes just to [ __ ] even it out
you know all right here we go
ladies get deprived - how we doing on
time oh good killing it well right on
schedule here all right ladies get
deprived - dear bill I am
lady in my late 20s and I need a male
perspective on something that's too
embarrassing to bring up with my friends
all right on a good day one might
consider me quite easy on the eyes I
exercise every day I have a natural look
ie not trashy 20 layers of makeup kind
of gal however I always make a case of
looking well put together even at home
see she gets it however my husband's a
fat [ __ ] anyways but for some reason in
the last year of my 5-year marriage my
husband denies me sex even if I only
want to service him he knows I like to
do it Jesus I don't want a [ __ ] yeah
this is bad
yeah this is bad this is when you know
I've got to start taking off the police
and getting out the blanket dude to take
a [ __ ] from another dude evening he
will be it's not the mouth dude it's the
stubble I think that that's what you
couldn't get fast
I almost got need to do a spit-take on
any given evening he will be sitting on
his desk working late and if I try to
initiate things by touching him and
kissing his neck he will say sorry babe
it's too late and I'm tired
same goes for when we are in bed it has
gotten to the point where I just you
know what I got this paranoid thing he's
cheating like a mofo huh either that or
he got replaced by a robot and they
haven't worked out the genitals yet
right right sorry babe it's too late and
I'm tired
what's wrong with your voice same goes
for when we are in bed it's gotten to
the point where I will try to approach
him in lingerie sit on his lap and even
go as far as begging for just five
minutes all without any success this is
like this is one of these things if it
was a news story I would shut it off
because I don't want to see the [ __ ]
ending here we go what baffles me is
that during normal day-to-day life he
will frequently grab my ass or tell me
I'm hot Wow
I also do the same for him as I know men
like to feel manly around their lady
this woman's like a dream I don't know
what's this guy's problem is the
possibility of an affair
I wonder okay the possibility she said
she's you know she's easy on the eye she
takes care of herself okay yeah I don't
know I got a nice picture of my head
anyways the possibility of an affair is
very unlikely seeing as we both work on
the same male-dominated company that's
not good and go home together also he
doesn't have a password in his phone I
think maybe he's gay male dominated on
earth something wrong
also he doesn't have a password in his
phone which is another huge indication
of nothing to hide we have a very nice
interaction I never nagged him if
anything he nags me and we do cool stuff
like play ball together or watch some
Netflix babies dick don't work no more
you don't want to tell her yet yeah you
could need to sit down and talk to him
he's a very loving husband except for
the actual physical loving part I've
tried to ask but everything is fine
everything is fine is in quote as it
appears bill can you please let me know
what the hell's going on aren't men
supposed to be always in the mood that's
not true but generally speaking yes I am
going crazy and I'm starting to get
aroused from the most ridiculous thing
like men smiling at me or opening the
door Jesus thank you I really enjoy
everything you're doing contrary to what
you think you are very balanced and
insightful in your opinions look at this
I got to read that to my wife happy
[ __ ] holidays and go [ __ ] [ __ ]
yourself one itching lady it's gonna get
[ __ ] I listen I think you've been nice
for long enough exactly you need to sit
down and be like look or leave him no no
no you gotta have a conversation first
first what is going on mm-hmm cuz you
know I'm about ready to get jump on a
rolling pin exactly what what the [ __ ]
are you doing it you need you need you
guys need to have a talk
need to go on and I wouldn't I would go
nice cuz just in case I did some
physical thing you gotta go nice first
year mm-hmm maybe maybe ten maybe he's
addicted to online porn that might be a
problem here but that definitely can't
continue what they're doing they seem
like they're around each other the whole
time I don't know what's going on you
get a lot of a lot of weird
yeah all right need advice quitting
drinking so I what I guess our advice is
I would sit down and talk to him
absolutely you're not being a nag at all
if anything you've been too nice and I
would just go easy just in case it's
something [ __ ] it's a problem yeah he
got molested as a kid it finally came
out no he doesn't like today ever used
to go at it like bunny rabbits is a good
question did y'all ever used to have
like a real healthy sexual relationship
and just fell off a cliff I always a
gradual or yeah I think once you have a
kid though that that just happens like
the appeal of
going to sleep is just [ __ ]
unbelievable it's unbeliev all right
need advice quitting drinking huh I know
you're I know you're at 100 something
odd days now of no drinking 116 days of
not drinking I'm at a whopping day 3 and
this is my third attempt in the last two
months to take some serious time off
most of my attempt only lasts three or
four days max because every Friday rolls
around and I can't help but buy some
booze I want to quit because my problem
is serious serious enough that I
experience minor withdrawals like minor
shakes Wow if I haven't had a drink in
like 12 to 16 hours meaning I'm
physically dependent yeah dude this is a
great reason to stop it's not serious to
the point where people notice I'm able
to keep it under control but drinking
everyday needs to stop yeah you're
what's known as the intelligent or
alcoholic so you can [ __ ] what I call
you you're a smart guy and your booze
and so you can place [ __ ] off and nobody
notices we're just a [ __ ] [ __ ]
everyone's gonna notice exactly my
question for you is how did you go about
filling up the boredom that comes with
being sober oh what a great [ __ ]
question I feel like I'm drinking when
I'm drinking anything is fun sitting
like which for hours it's so true on end
watching YouTube videos but when I'm
sober I've got like 20 minutes tops
before I'm bored with whatever I'm doing
also what was your prot was your problem
ever bad enough that you felt
withdrawals I know how to taper pretty
well at this point but
have failed so many times that if you
know of any tapering tips so basically
how to wean your way off I guess I'd
love to hear them PS I've always missed
the old overrated underrated segment you
used to do circa 2009 - on the podcast
you should bring that back or actually
bringing it back all right this week
we'll bring it back we'll keep doing it
if you guys want to send it in over
eight and under it I find when I stop
drinking when I stop it's it's tough for
like the first like six to ten days and
what it is I'm more habit addicted like
I just like if if I'm eating well like
I'm addicted to go I want to get a salad
if I'm eating like [ __ ] like I eat
McDonald's the next day I'm craving
McDonald's if I'm drinking then I want a
drink so it's basically I tried to be
conscious of those thoughts in my head
and just be like try to get to the next
morning going tomorrow morning what's
gonna make me happier that I had a drink
right now that I didn't and it was
always that I didn't so I would used to
do that at the Boston comedy club when
never really know what you had like I
never really seen you drunk ever back in
the day
yeah I'd in the last like like 15 years
I gradually just drank more and more and
more and more poor then I I just I'm not
getting alcoholic but I but if the
amount that I drink I absolutely am
right but I'm one of those guys I can
shut it off and like this guy just City
have you like shows you don't like I can
do it if I'm not performing I cannot
have a drink but if I'm performing I
need one or two but I'm not alcohol it
by far but I have other problems i thing
is like I if I'm doing something I'm
doing it so the first thing I do when I
sit down at a bar is I always order a
double because I'm assuming that they're
poor you said you'd go to the bar
destination leaving your house is the
bar or like houses do Garza at the shows
well by the sums this this summer it was
becoming like going to the liquor store
buying a bottle and always like I was on
the road do
an acting gig and I made sure I had a
ball and I just quit and I knew I was
shutting it down so I was just like this
is where it is bill this is bad
yeah it got it got way way WAY worse
than it everyone as far as like what am
i doing I remember coming home from the
set one night and being excited that the
bar was still open and before I went in
it's not wrong with there to where where
I would stay but I was by myself right
okay
and I ordered a double sucked it down
and said give me another double because
I was sort of addicted to that that
crazy buzz and then going asleep I think
I like a tube and then the whole time
wanting to stop are wanting to not do it
as much and that was the only time and
it's the first time ever my wife brought
it up going you know you're really
drinking a lot and then you're gonna
snore and blah blah blah blah and then
one night I came down
Good Wife mito I came downstairs and I
actually was hiding the glass of booze
on the other side of my life when I was
coming down the stairs then I was just
like whoa yeah I'm that guy now how soon
before the bottles in the back of the
toilet but I kind of too much of a
control freak to make it happen like
that so but I find like once I go ten
days the way I'm wired
I could go it's easy in theory I could
go forever okay cuz now it's just
something I don't do I'm just like I
like the the whatever it is that would
that had it's it's [ __ ] claws in me
it only takes 10 days for how I'm
chemically made up to just be like yeah
like right now I'm 116 days in I could
easily go a year I could go two years I
could I could like never drink again for
the rest of my life and I don't think
about it anymore like at the shows or no
there's certain things that like makes
me just wish I was still drinking and
I'm like what did I see the other day
that was just like oh man I would love
to do that like I saw some cool-looking
bar and it was just like man I would
love to go there at 2:00 in the
afternoon and just get [ __ ] drinking
till 6:00 get [ __ ] hammered but then
but now the way it plays out is Renova
flared oh I know I would
but nuber and i would come home drunk to
my daughter and it's like I can't have
that on the resume
no no so that's over so my life also
kind of I'm a time this guy needs to
have a kid so I would just say what you
need to do is you got to push through
that boredom and I put there's so much
fun [ __ ] that you can actually fill that
time up with that there's stuff that you
wanted to get good at like like I've
always been into music like playing
drums and playing guitar if you do that
instead or working out like if at night
yeah if at night you go out for a jog
instead and then this is nothing this is
nothing to about not drinking it's the
[ __ ] pounds just fall off you really
you know as long as you don't substitute
it with then like I'm gonna eat ice
cream so I can get like a sugar rush if
you actually eat well and you don't
booze yeah it just falls off here it's
got nowhere to hide so um I don't know
man but it sounds like you know that the
shakes and stuff you're on another level
than I was so I'm if I was you I might
even go to a meeting that's borderline
intervention TV show would you get two
shakes yeah a little bit I would go to a
meeting just check out a meeting just go
down there check it out sit in the back
have a [ __ ] doughnut whatever the hell
they do there and just listen to these
people's insane stories it'll actually
make you feel better about yourself
exactly all right okay here we go
overrated underrated bringing this back
this is something that's this guy said
so we actually we're gonna do one this
week this is something I used to do way
back in the day 2009 he's do overrated
underrated it was the thing of the week
whatever you thought was over it and
whatever was underrated all right
overrated Texas Hold'em underrated
five-card stud
now here's the deal I don't know [ __ ]
about cards I don't know you got to give
me the explanation all right that was a
bad that was a soft open yeah I don't
know anything about cars an open car all
right what do you think's overrated
right now this this topic no no what I
think is over 80 right now Oh hip hop
really yeah like didn't didn't
they're not having any words in your
song and it being quote-unquote a
classic ours a hot song for this time
and it but ten years down the road this
guy said nothing he was just he be in
sounds oh it's just beating since it's
like mumble rap like they don't they
don't say anything
Oh everybody yeah everybody sounds like
they're kind of like half in the bag
yeah
and there's no originality anymore but
people are still celebrating something
that is less original than it used to be
do you know old you sound right now
well the people in your generation
gangsta rapper now but originality is
not all that's that's your arrest
Universal and they don't have anyway
when it's an original that their names
not even different look how many little
rappers do we have little this little
that little you can't even name yourself
an original name all right when did they
live when did hip-hop lose you mmm
probably the mid 2000 no late 2008 mm mm
11 12 on and up but no you won't you
hung in there yeah but not all hip-hop
nights you got artists like Eminem and
nozzles still doing what they supposed
to do god you're doing like that's like
me going you know Zeppelin an ac/dc yeah
going back like 20 years but those guys
are still rapping those gay and it's
still relevant and still words like you
got you can't have a song wouldn't its
instrumental what about the who's a
girlie Awards me goes the meek is it V
me goes I don't even know when you don't
listen to him I don't even know I heard
of him but I'm not okay I know a lot of
rappers name got little in it and that
bugs me little woozy vert just change
the name to original name little Wayne
was first and in everybody else's a
little bit my Tupac and Biggie they had
their own names not its original name
yeah he went there he went little
because there was already a to short who
is who is the the little person there
and that [ __ ] guy was that [ __ ] I
don't know anybody there was a guy Bush
Bush yeah he was no he didn't even say
little know he was bill said where he's
from well you know these Millennials are
sensitive okay I would say overrated
being informed
it's overrated absolutely I am off
social medias I don't read the [ __ ]
anymore I post my [ __ ] on there but I'm
done like oh I [ __ ] took a picture of
this thing too this is the classic
classic it's gonna take forever to turn
my phone on so I'm just gonna keep going
classic [ __ ] like a joke when you
forgot the punchline just keep repeating
the setup oh yeah [ __ ] is crazy she's
crazy also say we should say when when
comic white comics were lost in their
act
they'd look down and be like yeah yeah
so what else is going on matcom [ __ ] is
crazy
yeah she's crazy out here for the ladies
ladies all the strong women in the crowd
they're always strong women are always
strong I used to do that so I wouldn't
bomb early like in black rooms like I'll
just go give it up for the ladies and
and complement the crowd enough so
they'll give me at least 30 more seconds
not to boo me what's the hardest room
you ever did
sweet cheese sweet cheeks back to sweet
cheeks
it's not even our own thing is look like
it's just a [ __ ] place to go get pick
up $200 it was a 250 back there oh yeah
that was literally like fighting might
like Mike Tyson yes just like all right
if I can survive around I get I get my
[ __ ] purse all right this is
something that somebody tweeted today
about that pipe bomb that went off on in
the the Port Authority it was yeah
fortunately nobody died they said there
was none I like non-life-threatening
injuries but that doesn't mean somebody
didn't lose an eye or [ __ ] hearing a
song bomb went off on 23rd Street right
by Gotham comedy club and they closed
the street off
I thought you can do a joke no and so
just got offstage when I got there they
was the street was closed off and I
actually asked the cop but but I haven't
told the cop I have a spot I didn't give
a [ __ ] about Tommy
I just want to do my spot well this this
what this [ __ ] jerk-off tweets about
the Port Authority bum he goes I have no
idea what's going on at the Port
Authority but it was chaotic and I
didn't stay to find out so you have no
idea what's going on but we had to find
out how you felt about what you did know
what's happening look is a
you did people down there hurt you
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is what I can't
stand I'll be an old man yet about young
people now nobody cares about every
[ __ ] thought and your stupid [ __ ]
head aches are you there
did you see what happened do you have
any information you see I have no idea
what's going on at Port Authority but it
was chaotic and I didn't stay to find
out and then there's gonna be a thousand
[ __ ] people going so happy you're
okay yeah exactly
people just wanna I don't know so many
people wanted to be known know all these
[ __ ] people with the reason you know
at least [ __ ] look on social media
it's like they have their own TV show
and they're acting like celebrities
self-involved [ __ ] celebs as opposed
to cool ones like us the one that's
already skill sorry sorry alright last
one here we go
how do I tell the truth hey Bill well
I've been thinking with my dick I
recently downloaded the popular hookup
app tinder and I've been using it to
fish for some action with some college
chicks in my area I'm pretty
good-looking and I'm not bad with chicks
so I've had moderate success I recently
found this one chick in my area who is
all pre-med is that all one word pyaari
meed okay thank you it was like I knew I
was dumb I didn't ago was that [ __ ]
dumb um you know what's funny that
[ __ ] guy who said the guy who I was
telling this story about like you know
funny how like things going in and out
of your ass he just sent me a text like
a [ __ ] ring say I recently found this
chick in my area who's premed I really
like spending time with her and we have
the same sense of humor and political
beliefs and she has an excellent body
and face and short she's pretty close to
my ideal girl however there's one
problem I'm in high school and she has
no idea this guy dude you dude you were
a legend you should be giving me advice
I have dodged most of her questions
about the classes I take and where I
couldn't dodge I lied oh Jesus we
haven't done anything physically but she
made it cleared she is interested in me
I'm in deep bill how do I tell her
without her hating me do I have to tell
her I just [ __ ] tell her just say
listen
I don't want to go to a physical level
without [ __ ] telling you the truth
I'm still in high school I really liked
you I would have told you sooner but I
was afraid you weren't gonna like me
just do that put it out on the table if
she tells you to go [ __ ] yourself fine
but you've learned a very valuable
lesson with women which I wish somebody
taught me way back in my teen years teen
years
just tell them the truth mm-hmm what are
we doing I want to [ __ ] you I have no
intention of having a relationship with
you okay most will walk away some won't
but Yuki you can literally leave your
[ __ ] car out in the front of your
house and it will never be keyed none of
your [ __ ] will be lit on video you're
honest yes yes that's why when I when I
see guys who talk but honesty is always
the best policy because you'll have to
worry about people getting mad and doing
crazy [ __ ] to you dude it works with
cops too cops and women nobody lies gets
lied to more than those two when you
actually come with the truth even if
they don't like the truth it kind of
like yeah you might not get a ticket
that's probably why Patrice won't fire
that no one no one we didn't get in
trouble yeah cuz he was [ __ ] honest
about what happened damn I try I [ __ ]
bang this you turn right and I Friday's
I did it this [ __ ] cop got out of his
car and as I'm pulling up and thinking
maybe he didn't see it he's just
coincidentally getting out and he walks
right up to my window he goes let me see
a driver's license of registration it's
like a [ __ ] he goes he goes you know why
I'm asking for that and I was like yeah
and he goes why go cuz I just made an
illegal u-turn and he goes why did you
do that I go cuz I'm impatient I didn't
want to wait in that line in there and
he's just laughed and he goes do you
want me to give you would you want me to
give you a ticket I said no but I'm not
gonna lie to you and he's laughed again
he goes alright get out of here
I said you're awesome right that was it
then other times I've told the truth and
like all the way to the point is this
your current address and I said no and
the guy wrote me up for everything and
my [ __ ] address and I was like this
[ __ ] he trying to get [ __ ]
cop of the month I did that in western
New York
alright we're out of time Paris yes so
great to see you dude once again
Bitterman your album my comedy album is
coming out is out already it's out right
now on iTunes Amazon
and Google Play in anywhere else that
you can get comedy anywhere else yes the
name of the album is naive innocence
okay
I almost said Google alert is where you
can get it like I don't know what the
[ __ ] anything is all right thank you so
much for stopping by thank you for the
podcast appreciate and everybody I
forgot to mention here we got a couple
of benefits stuff here Santa Steve the
great Steve Simone and regular hero are
raising money again this year for
children fighting cancer and their
families that's worded really weird
they're fighting cancer and the families
of the children fighting cancer they're
not weird they're raising money again
this year for children fighting cancer
and they're these kids are fighting
cancer and their own families the
children and their families fighting
cancer
Monday morning podcast listeners helped
raise 15 grand last month and it had a
huge impact on a lot of families the
stories are brutal and every bit helps
we're gonna save you the [ __ ] stories
okay the goal this year is to raise 50
grand we're gonna tweet a link thank you
so much in ahead of time if you got
anything to give and also hit some dates
I got coming up I'm gonna be at the Hard
Rock live in Hollywood Florida
December 14th December 16th the Bob Carr
Theatre in Orlando Florida
February 2nd the Reno ballroom Reno
Nevada
February 20th the Patrice O'Neal comedy
event benefit the sixth annual makes a
great Christmas gift get a pair of
tickets to that tickets have been going
fast it's a great benefit raising money
for Patrice's mom and loved ones thank
you guys so much go [ __ ] yourselves and
I'll check in on you on Thursday